[Music]
I just don't want to find myself at 50
and some block association meeting
trying to prevent the opening of a new
bar sutures we're not starting 56th
Street I'm 47 a baby is an immoral act
overpopulation climate change rising
neo-fascism took your family yes yeah
why they're trying it by any means
necessary approached I thought they were
done with all that and they were trying
to adopt they're still doing that
they're like fertility junkies
their best chance for success is with
donor-egg he's out of his mind there's a
lot of positives well it's easy for you
to say you'll have your genetic
contribution and me I'm just left out
[Music]
uncle Richard and aunt Rachel said I
could stay at their place anytime I want
to
they're not in any position to take care
of anyone but themselves right now my
mom told me you guys had a lot going on
but I had no idea this is a really bad
time for me to be crashing yours really
because I have friends in before so
they're here so how's college going
everyone is so convinced of their own
artistic promise and I'm like hey my
uncle is an award-winning theater genius
and my aunt is a real-life playwright
and there are over 40 and still have to
live in a rent stabilized apartment at a
venue a with like drunks and graffiti in
the front don't talk to me about the
sacrifices you're making to be an artist
okay
[Music]
we are doing everything we can short of
kidnapping to start a family what do you
think to give your unborn child to these
people totally I wish you were my
parents sometimes I feel closer to you
than everyone else in the family happy
anniversary
[Music]
we need to take some responsibility for
the situation a lot of women have babies
at 41 that thought I could - one two
three
[Music]
you